[Music]
[Applause]
Conan O'Brien here is my video blog
here's what's going on in my world today
I had kind of a bad morning I went to
the Avengers movie I thought it'd be
cool to wear my Batman costume I thought
turns out he's not in the movie he's the
only superhero who's not on the movie
and all these kids are making fun of me
they're whipping Milk Duds at me anyway
here's my review the Avengers is the
worst Batman movie I've ever seen pretty
sight though because I think I invented
a new snack today I took check it out I
took a slim jim and I stuck it through a
Twinkie I call it a slinky
our next segment is called animal dorks
and animal dorks
these are photos of wild animals this
just looks sort of like dorks like this
hammerhead shark is rushing to the comic
book store this cat owns every weird al'
album this monkey taught himself how to
speak Klingon right here this dog is
like the mayor of dorks Vil look at that
guy
spend a lot of time on that here's
something cool a lot of people have been
asking what Andy does while I'm doing my
video blogs so I set up a spy cam to
keep an eye on Andy let's check it out
no idea he's not meeting you're dead
right now
oh just messing around on my computer
that's good that's great
all right settle down man all right now
it's time for our final segment
it's called Mitt Romney Mitt Romney this
is where I take old prom photos and
replace all of their faces with Mitt
Romney's face there's one right here
[Applause]
here's another one right here
bunch of people having a good time
[Laughter]
that was a little thing I call Mitt
Romney
[Applause]